Let's take everything away except our picture of the prototype relationship
between these two objects and consider this relationship just on its own.
If this behavior was useful to us for
making the rose object capable of resembling the gold object,
are there other objects in JavaScript that might make use of this mechanism?
For example, does gold delegate its own field lookup somewhere?
In fact it does.
There is a top level object that every JavaScript object
eventually delegates to.
This is where all the basic methods are provided for all objects.
We call it the object prototype because it provides the shared properties of
all objects in the entire system.
That way, when you ask an object for its dot to string property,
you get access to a function that can do the appropriate work.
Once you've accessd the function, you can immediately call it.
And the object that you did the property look up on will appear to the left of
the dot at that functions call time.
Thanks to the way that the parameter this works, the shared function will work
as expected, with the this keyword bound to the rose object, even though
the .toString method was technically stored way up on the object prototype